hi I'm Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan in today's video I'm
going to do a follow-up question to a
previous ask if in video we did before
with one of our readers Elizabeth now
Elizabeth runs a website that helps
artists and it was all free just given
information and profoundly if an artist
and was looking for ways to monetize the
site and thinking of what to do next
with that company since it was maybe
fulfilling for her but wasn't providing
an income stream and my recommendation
at the time was to go out and instead of
selling advertising something she had
thought about go out and create your own
product and when you have a loyal
audience what you'll find is they're
more likely to buy your product in the
click on ads because the ads are you
know the people have been our blindness
and they're less likely put on the eye
so new visitors to website and click on
ads repeat visitors woke up the knots
what they will buy products so now she's
just launching a new product and then
one of my advice on kind of had to build
that up if she's on the right strategy
how to grow the business so Elizabeth
typically the process is you have a
whole bunch of people on your free site
and what you're doing is building a
final so you have these 30,000 people
that you're reaching and that's free and
that's going out every week you said on
Thursday and that's great you want to
keep that up it's fulfilling to help a
lot of people you still provide a lot of
great valuable information and what
you're doing there is building up a
community helping with your SEO getting
people to learn about the company you
have the offerings that you have and
then from there a small percentage will
go on to want to buy whatever product or
service you have but I wouldn't give up
that 30,000 you still want to keep that
freebase going you still want to grow
that as much as you can keep it targeted
towards the community you're going after
provide still a lot of great information
be seen as the expert for your industry
and even though you're not monetizing
most of them small percentage will sign
up for whatever program you're trying to
sell now what you usually find is the
the market is to do a really good job
with this online they start with a
really low priced product
something like seven bucks or ten bucks
just low price product to get people to
start getting used to spending money
with you so it's not just a free thing
but they're actually open up their
wallet and give me money and then from
there they start increasing the prices
with other products giving even more
value and once somebody's bought from
you wants and they're really happy with
it they're more likely to want to buy
again in Montgomery game so you give a
really low price product but high value
and people who buy up somehow this is
really great Elizabeth has great stuff I
want to keep going on with her and doing
more and more with her and it's a low
entry point for them so your first
product is 200 bucks or 500 bucks or
something expensive most people are not
going to want to do it because it's it's
pricey and so there's a high risk
associated with it whereas if you start
with something cheaper it's easier to
get somebody to open up the wall and say
yes and then you start building a
relationship with them even more than
what you had and gable to up sell more
products typically you find that model
is seven dollar product fifty dollar
product then a hundred dollar or two
hundred product and then they'll move up
to things like live events or coaching
which might be thousands of dollars but
you're building this funnel and at the
top you know you have very few people
who are spending a lot of money and then
it starts going down from there until
you get to the free who aren't spending
anything with you but your goal with
each step is to move people from one
step to the next step to the next step
so more and more people start spending
money with you now that may be a lot to
take in considering you just launching
your first product so you know it's
great where you're starting it's a great
starting point to get going with your
first product you might want to thank
what other products could I sell after
this one so i can get recurring
customers buying more and more from me
so these is what a great business is to
sell more to existing customers than to
try to go up and get new customers so
having addition of products can help you
do that so definitely on the right path
keeping their train that freebase keep
offering them a lot of value don't make
it too salesy still have a lot of good
information that they want to check out
and they look forward to your emails
every thursday and then slowly introduce
your your product a certain percentage
will take it and that's fine you keep
working with them and introducing the
parts as well
so it's great deep launching first
product then that keep me posted when
you got your second and third one out
and how you're doing if you have
questions of course that we know so for
those of you who are watching thank you
and if you like the video please give it
a thumbs up and I'd love to hear what
you have to think if you have any other
advice or I'd love to hear your
experience as well if you want to leave
a comment underneath the video and stay
tuned for next episode
you